it's friday and that means it's time for
friday follies for that we turn the
tables
joining me now is the true host of the
ingram angle author of the book of dei
zing
laura ingram
i have a new book okay it's kind of
modeled after your titles a little bit
it's like
the guy who always has a book to promote
by laura and you're on the cover oh good
thank you i'll i'll go out and promote
that next week after the thief who stole
heaven anyway laura
as you've chronicled the biden
administration has a habit of shifting
story lines there's no border crisis
then there's a border crisis
trump didn't vaccinate enough people we
just vaccinated as many
and exceeded our goal now biden has
announced
this when president harris and i took
a virtual tour of a vaccination center
in arizona
not long ago president harris sadly
this is not the first time we've heard
this story this is a person who is ready
on day one
to be president united states of america
a harris
administration together with joe biden
my name is joe biden
i'm jill biden's husband and i am
commonly running mate
laura what do you think is going on here
is there more here
than than meets the eye or the ear it's
the art of
projection uh transference
it maybe he can see into the future he's
a clairvoyant raymond so biden has many
talents
all right well raymond at least at least
biden is no longer planning
what the inauguration of cory booker the
fact is that
the bills that the president that excuse
me the future president here that
that that the senator's talking about
are bills that were passed
years ago and they were passed
overwhelmingly you know laura a friend
of mine used to say
slips of the tongue belie slips of the
mind belies slips of the heart
this man may not want to be president
and certainly doesn't think you'll be
there for long
something's going on here we'll unpack
this in the days ahead the president may
not be promoting cory booker but he's
having
all kinds of syntax trouble here's
today's
freestylin biden joe where are you come
here
[Music]
we developed nearly we deployed nearly 6
000
federal personnel we've got to reach the
point
where we have heard immunity meaning
where we have a vast
majority of the american people have
been vaccinated don't let us happen you
see happening in europe and you see on
television
laura what is the march 25th press
conference going to look like
that's my that's my one question i i'm
pretty sure he fell asleep
somewhere in the middle of those that
compilation or maybe i did
yeah he just didn't know where he was
he's law and that's with a teleprompter
these are very short rehearsed events i
just don't know how he's going to do in
a free exchange but laura the pandemic
has made so many activities virtual
even for joe biden school instruction
public meetings
even congressional hearings have now
entered zoom doom
that's where people stare into the
camera asking
can you hear me can you hear me laura i
think we lost laura
this is from a congressional hearing
today congressman matt sue you were
recognized for five minutes
apparently there's a technical problem
with webex and not with my
ipad doris can you hear me
i'm experiencing the same thing uh we
can hear you if you can hear us
wave your arms they can't hear us
wait well now this is the technology
wave your arms he looks like a broken
the only thing missing was the stem on
his head he kept touching his face and
his mask looks like a pumpkin
well at this point i'm waiting for them
to say blink if you can hear me in morse
code
these are the people who are entrusted
with trillions of
dollars and they can't even run a zoom
meeting
it sure it's a glaring picture of how
incompetent
this government is at so many levels and
yet people want to entrust them with
health care
education of their children and i guess
not trillions you can give away i'm
gonna go a step further
the republicans should uh uh put forward
legislation
that puts an end to these zoom hearings
if you have something to say you've all
gotten your vaccinations i think they
pretty much all have they're
in session you got to be in town okay
enough of this this is
they want to continue this remote zoom
congress you know forever if they if
they had their way they would never come
back to washington
but they'd keep the barbed wire and the
razor wire up
no i agree with you something's got to
be done here and look next time
congresswoman rashida taleb hosts a
reading event for kids as she did the
other day
she might want to tell people to check
their language before handler
looks like the kitten gardeners yay oh i
love mark mark twain
elementary middle school this is great
i'm gonna start
okay uh excuse me uh can you please mute
your phone
oh my gosh
i got kids on your phone
dropped an f-bomb in the middle of this
reading event laura by the way
that is the staffer of a michigan state
senator a woman in her bio who describes
herself as
having a natural ability to be
personable and relatable
i think her talents might be better used
in a bar room not with kids
just saying raymond like the zoom
zoom doom is a great way to describe it
you know
webex mess whatever whatever we want to
call this
it's not working okay it doesn't work
except for
short insignificant uh quickie
conversations and even then
you got to see people face to face sans
masks where you can read express well
with the background
immunity i want the human touch and
togetherness people need that
laura thank you have a great weekend